so a woman is advertising for a farmer
to marry her best friend these two girl
these gorgeous girls oh my god beyond
gorgeous wait those are just regular
girls regular girls from new zealand one
of them moved to farm country
and to marry a farmer and she has a
friend named amber who wants to live the
farm life too like so they can all be
like four farmers together going on date
nights to the barn i'm
literally not okay this is get you a
friend like liv and this is the two of
them that must be liv they're literally
both so beautiful i cannot believe this
isn't a story about models like yeah
those girls look like that and they're
not famous that's not what it's like
you're advertising for a boyfriend when
you look like that no there's no hope
for any of you go home
go home if this girl needs to put up a
billboard i've never seen a more
beautiful girl in my life and that's
just like a regular facebook photo it's
not an edited instagram page there's no
filter on it there's no like colors
there's no bisco i'm literally like
upset like i put on full glam today for
this stupid show i look like a rat
you'll never be amber no and i'll never
be amber with no makeup on at a vineyard
you know